برعايه سعوديه عمليه تبادل اسرى بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
وساطه ولي العهد السعودي تنجح بالافراج عن
عشره اسرار
[موسيقى]
الاسرى المحررون من خمس جنسيات المغرب
وامريكا وبريطانيا والسويد وكرواتيا
السعوديه نقلت الاسرى من روسيا الى الرياض
الحادي والعشرون من سبتمبر 2022 وصول
الاسرى العشره الى السعوديه
تاييد دولي واسع لوساطه ولي العهد السعودي
نشكر شركائنا السعوديين على المساعده في
قياده هذه المبادره الانسانيه وتسهيل عوده
عشره رعايه اجانب بمنفهم مواطناني
امريكيان استقبلهما فريق سفاراتنا في
الرياض
كانت مبادره جيده نظرا للعلاقات التي
يمتلكها ولي العهد مع روسيا كانت فرص
النجاح مرتفعه وانا ممتن جدا له على هذه
النتيجه الرائعه
طبعا الازمه في اوكرانيا منذ بدايتها وعرض
وساطتها على الطرفان على
روسيا واوكرانيا لايجاد حلها ومنذ ذلك
الحين وهو يتابع التطورات وعند عما علم عن
موضوع هذول الاسرى وصعوبه
خروجهم والتعقيدات لانها كانت عمليه معقده
حقيقه منذ ابريل بدا في الحوار مع الاطراف
وعمل عليها
استمرار خلال الفتره الماضيه الى حين تمت
الصفقه وخرجوا والان في طريقهم الى اهله
فكان هذا نتيجه حقيقه لاستمرار سموه في
متابعه الامر وحواره المباشر مع جميع
الاطراف